[موسيقى]
اجمل النجوم الثريا واجمل ما بالكون القمر
واذا اجتمع جمالين الجمال الكون يا القمر
مع جمال النجوم قال العامه القمر جارنا
ثريا فالمقارنه معناها الاجتماع فاذا وقع
القمر بجانب الثريا في اليوم الخامس من
الشهر الهجري فهذا اماره وعلامه على تفشي
وانتشار الربيع ولا يجتمع في هذا اليوم
الا مره واحده والعامه يقولون جراند خامس
ربيعا طامس
[تصفيق]
واهم الاقترانات سته اثنين شتوي الاقتران
الحادي عشر والتاسع واثنين الربيعي السابع
والخامس واثنين صيفي الثالث والاقتران
الاول والاقتران الخامس اخر الاقترانات
الربيعيه وسنستمتع بالربيع خلال شهرين
شعبان ورمضان بحول الله وخلال هذا
الاقتران يبدا شعاع الشمس بل احترار هام
الفؤاد باعرابيه سكنت بيتا من القلب لم
تمدد له طنوبه كانها شمس يعي كفثقه بضه
شعاعها ويراه الطرف
مغتربه
[موسيقى]